like you gotta put your pinkie oh this
is my favorite in San Diego I want
[Music]
hi I'm Alexis and I'm a beautiful San
Diego my friend God yells gonna show me
around the city so good to see so good
to see you too I've got you a little
something thank you welcome to San Diego
it's such a beautiful day here I moved
here ten years ago when I joined the
military and I just fell in love with
the city
my goal here is for you to fall in love
with the city we have a couple of places
plan that you're gonna love I have no
doubt thank you so much for your service
I can't wait to see what you've got in
store let's do it let's have some fun me
number is Maria I'm hella co-sponsor
lady Maria Maria I'm her adopted son
she's my adopted mother I first came
down here when I was in the military
this is like the closest I will get to
the milligan pool way la primera Fonda
Dora is soon drinkin cito salarino in la
ciudad a San Diego estamos haciendo
Cinco
[Music]
Sam presume Plateau que vive de todo un
poco que le voy a preparar July yuca
past Alito enchilada the man lays
pupusas that we call Chi Charo this is
for the pupusa de comida salvador enemy
no mas typical neza comida a small
phrase estamos al momento Hassan dope
and oh no kidding no lo tenemos hecho
demo be emotional
- loco para pravara for me vino de todo
para que approval of comida no see oh I
told over for me
she says she won she was the okuda you
yama yamaha circa Pusa
the first time woman a is the pupusa
Mira que bonito y la pupusas is una
tortilla they say are say they maximize
this pork chop early in the morning she
sees in him
so I died like okay ready to go there's
also onion on top of an onion has its
own seasoning
so yoga is empanadas and she's put it in
here because there's no meat in here
pelota no right here we have the tamales
and this is the enchilada it's so good
[Music]
so you started coming here 10 years ago
but now you're a family how did that
happen I tried this once and I was like
yo this is so good I kept coming back
out came back like almost every week for
10 years that's free I even went to
their daughters quinceañera early part
of the family really proud of them I
think you got the vegan one ah I made
that one you made it yeah really
yeah first read the cuts that means okay
there's too much food there's no such
thing as too much this is the Holy Grail
I mean the food is absolutely I think
what's so cool like I would have never
discovered this on my own
this feels like so off the radar and the
best way you walk in it feels like
stepping into her house every time
people come down innocent
here let's finish up this food because
I'm gonna have some more place we got a
long day ahead this is La Jolla Cove
it's so gorgeous here this is a place
where I like to take people when they're
visiting San Diego I feel like this is a
must-see it feels really special the
turquoise water all the birds the seals
we just got done eating salad a new now
we're gonna Lucha Libre yeah definitely
need to walk it off first I was walking
uh-oh let's go
[Music]
we're here at Lucha Libre this is
actually lucha libres first location for
the esthetic you're gonna love it the
burrito is amazing it's to kill for you
ready let's go my name is socially Rohan
oh I'm one of the owners of lucha libre
taco shop here in sunny San Diego we
took a really Mexican concept which is
freestyle wrestling and we merged it
with Mexican food and that's what Lucha
Libre is all about San Diego invented
the California burrito and we put french
fries in our burrito that might be weird
for people but here in San Diego that's
what we do surfing California's is the
most popular one it was actually my
brother's you mentioned surf and turf
Reno California burrito you know and if
you put them together and you wanted to
use better products our steak which is
our marinade at Atena our shrimp which
we cook on the grill with a little bits
of secret sauce I can't tell you about
my mom's the one that came up with that
one I was a real fan of garlic so it's
very garlicky we actually get Kennebec
potatoes which is a really good frying
potato so we take our tortilla you put
that mean shrimp french fries pico de
gallo cheese which is a Monterey Jack
and avocado slices and then we top it
off with our super-secret chipotle sauce
we pulled that up into this huge brittle
it was all about freshness and quality
we call your name on a very obnoxious
microphone like in the ring so reserve
the champion see so our champs booth is
really funny it's full service you don't
have to wait in line you ring for
service that's right we give you mass so
you guys can take pictures it's a really
fun experience this looks crazy we until
Jill you gotta be a good friend in town
I thought the French fries are gonna be
soggy but it's not at all it feels like
crispy potato and it feels that good
long
definitely for the shrimp and the steak
together mm-hmm
this is a really solid burrito this is
also a massive for you my bag you can
eat like half of this Briona take the
other half of later now it's two minutes
I'm right champion let's get out of here
we're gonna go to a little brewery Blinn
and after that we're gonna somewhere
very special perfect day furries are
bigger San Diego I've heard this is one
of my favorite places and I think you're
gonna love it we're gonna eat good I
think we should drink good what better
place than battle I'm ready that's a
Dominican say that's amazing I think
this is my I think this one was my
favorite
it all good they're all smooth I feel
like this beer is perfect to go to the
beach palace Winston around turkey duck
it's right well it's been around since
1996 but before that it was homebrew
Mart which is one of the pioneers of the
breweries in sense what started this
whole thing yes this is quality work it
really is are you ready for dinner
[Music]
we're here at Crafton Commerce I always
wanted to eat here but I feel like this
is now the perfect excuse to try Amazo
let's do it
you want them yeah you ready so ready ha
today let's go eat some bone marrow hi
my name is Ted Smith I'm the executive
chef at Crafton ecommerce restaurant in
San Diego we're kind of eclectic and
food a lot of the menus focused on a
wood-burning grill that we have in the
oven so we do a lot of open fire cooking
well there was a lot that went in the
design here it was great piecing behind
us like that was actually done by the
guy at the Natural History Museum here
in San Diego what we're really focused
on here is hospitality and then trying
to steer you in the direction to having
a great experience really for the menu
it was about trying to pull some of what
San Diego is known for and just to keep
things really fresh and seasonal and the
oysters they're called mint or sweets
they're from Washington they're grilled
over the open flame with a little bit of
butter that Browns in there a nice
ethiopian red curry sauce to add a
little bit heat a little bit of garlic
to that the oysters is one of the most
popular dishes on the menu through the
wood grilled oysters with Ethiopian red
curry sauce so what fire that's right
sir this is beautiful
they just went for it usually we eat one
of these it's very chewy this is how it
should be I was expect that I may be
like a fishy taste
there was like no Fisher case no nothing
this is quantity what with the bone
marrow we do that over the open flame as
well so there's a nice char on the bone
so we put that bone there just a perfect
temperature is our would build bone now
I've got you madam this is incredible
I'm gonna grab a bone so I'm just gonna
scoop with the bone marrow out and put
it onto this toast this looks amazing
that's a good idea but you're an
adventurous eater I eat anything
it's like buttery and salty but not too
salty is very soft and like Jenny the
whole grilled fish that's coming up from
Baja Mexico I saw this true moment it's
kind of similar to a chimichurri so this
is a whole grilled golden spot bash
we've long some black and white rice and
arugula and fennel salad
[Music]
it's just like flaking right it's like
Irby this is all over the fire
everything is this amazing smokiness to
it this has been such an amazing day and
this meal is like the perfect way to end
it I can't thank you you're welcome ger
for sure then I'd been my job I had so
many awesome experiences to choose from
in San Diego and now I get to choose how
to pay for them with peut planet from
American Express it's been such a
special day the vibe mission here is
complete this is one of the best cities
in the world this has been friend to
town San Diego follow me along to see
the rest of the West Coast and see what
else is nice
oh yes
[Music]
you